Fritzie just saw the news that Kobe
Bryant's gonna be inducted with the
20/20 class in the Basketball Hall of
Fame
Reggie Miller is a member of the
Basketball Hall of Fame Turner Sports
NBA analyst reg normally with us on
Tuesday but given the circumstances
wanted to be on today talk about Kobe
Bryant hi reg good morning Theodor my
Danette look this is gonna be a tough
one for me because you know I felt that
I really helped raise this young man oh
Kobe was 17 or 18 when he joined aren't
elem at the time are our agent and I
just vividly remember the conversation
since I was 1 in the senior you know
Statesman of the agency you know he
won't really wanted me to kind of talk
and mentor to Kobe you know the young
flashy you know Philadelphia kid coming
in and just kind of you know tell him
and show him you know direct him down
the right NBA path but I was like sure
you know I'm down for that
so you know a lot of conversations with
young Kobe and his main focus was not
only to be great we all we all know that
but he loved Michael Jordan and he
wanted to be the next Jordan and you
know at that time MJ and I were heading
but had button one another and going at
it was during you know some of those
playoffs runs bursts of Chicago that one
epic seven-game series and he wants to
know every little thing that we you know
the trash-talking that went back and
forth between he and I what was this
move he did against you that move you
did against him he was the little detail
you wanted to know and I'm like wow this
kid well I know all this stuff you don't
like yeah really but he was taking notes
he was all ready for venting formulating
a plan
and to see him grow over the years to
where he and I were having issues and
problems and fights but none of that
matters because the true competitor that
Kobe is it I kind of this day resembles
and I remember coming on your show as
well as when Michael Jackson passed away
and I remember talking to you on this
show saying I cried like a baby and I
was like I don't care if people know I
was crying like a baby yesterday because
a lot like Michael Jackson we opened our
home to Kobe at such a young age I mean
he was a kid coming to us so we embraced
him we saw him grow up in front of us
and it is just a I cannot believe this
Theodore I cannot and you know I
appreciate you coming on reg it's just
like Jerry West who's gonna come on at
the top of the hour I I didn't know I
juggled with the sensitivity of this
because I know that you you know Kobe
you knew Kobe you helped raise him as
you say and then how do you put into
words because you never think you're
gonna have this moment at age you know
41 you're you're looking at saying
goodbye to somebody who's 41 years of
age and so I whatever words you have we
appreciate and everybody certainly
understands the emotion attached to this
I like the fact that it adds to it too
as well as you know there was nine total
people lost in this and in the families
in the tragedy but GG has done it it
just compounds it as well because you
know she was going to be the next one
and you see them at all these sporting
events you know at the UConn games she
came to the UCLA women's games the men's
games the or you know they've been a lot
of places together watching basketball
and you see him tutoring and teaching
her whispering in her ear
it's it's somewhat surreal because all
the knowledge all what I just mentioned
about him taking notes he was taking
notes Mellon for himself to be a
five-time champion two-time gold
medalists win an Oscar and he is
supplying all this information over all
these years since he was 17 years old
professionally and he's given it to his
four daughters and his wife it's you
know it's paying it forward and it's it
was beautiful to see and watch you saw
him at Laker game recently didn't you a
couple of months ago I did I did it and
no we hugged and we talked because it
was funny the Kobe that and the
relationship he and I have had over the
last since he's retired his last year
and retired was great when we played you
know at that shooting guard position it
was cut or be cut right it was you know
you were going coming for people's head
and he was such a competitor and you
know Jimmy he was a throwback player to
the 80s and 90s when I played because he
he literally would do whatever it took
to win and he wanted to embarrass you I
loved that about him because I was very
much the same way I wanted to embarrass
you Kobe wanted to embarrass you in
front of your family and friends and I
love to players like that and it's
probably one of the biggest reasons and
probably why we didn't get along on the
court it's because we were so much alike
we're talking to Reggie Miller the Hall
of Famer Turner Sports NBA analyst I the
word I keep coming up with when I just
like you know I mentioned the name I he
was always curious I loved his curiosity
and you mentioned this about basketball
he was curious with life and and trying
to figure out things he I don't think he
was ever embarrassed or ashamed to not
know something he was embarrassed or
ashamed if he didn't try to know
something that he just wanted there was
a thirst there so I could understand
where he just started accumulating all
this information on being a great
basketball player but also at the time
Regin you were there when Tracy McGrady
was the next Michael Jordan or Grant
Hill
was the next Michael dribbly we kept
kind of christening that's the next
Michael Jordan Kobe wanted to be the
next Michael Jordan these other players
were like I don't know I don't know if I
want to be Michael Jordan Kobe's like oh
my god yeah I mean what better
complementing you're gonna say I'm the
next Michael Jordan he I think we wanted
him to become the next Michael Jordan he
emerged as the original Kobe Bryant you
know a day after maybe two days after
that seven-game loss that I had against
MJ's daddy and the Bulls he calls me and
we're having a conversation about that
game and you know I keep referring to MJ
is that black cat you know I like that
black cat man he you know he just kept
willing those guys you know we have them
down he was struggling but he would you
know he kept the pressure on us and you
know that you remember that move he did
and you know it was stone silence on the
other than the phone he's like you know
what I'm gonna become the caramel
caramel cat because I was so upset after
that series because I wanted to retire
MJ and I'm thinking oh right here so
this is why I wanted you on today
because I know yesterday hurt but today
should celebrate and and that's it's
important to hear that he was too good
to not celebrate and and I know
yesterday was tough for you and that's
why I didn't reach out I'm glad you
reached out to me because I hope it's a
little cathartic for you to talk about
fun things and really what made him a
special player let's remember those
unbelievable epic games these heads but
also all the things he did in the
Philadelphia and Los Angeles community
and taking care of kids he always was a
champion of the underdog
we know his greatness on the court that
will forever be an images and videos and
pitch
we know that we get that a lot of people
didn't see what he was doing behind the
scenes in helping people this she was
helping people so please remember that
and let's celebrate that
let's celebrate Kobe it's great to be
sad and cry look I was painful yesterday
I was broken but I am going to celebrate
Kobe Bryant hey you got a game this week
well did they turner they switched us
and put me on that Lakers Clippers game
Tuesday so it's going to be great to be
a part of that in be in that atmosphere
oh boy and still that love will and feel
that love it's going to be a tough game
but I'm just so glad that Turner put me
on this game we're having studi guys
come out charles check i I can only
imagine what Shaq is going through I
mean we this is this is a family that
you you don't understand the blood sweat
and tears it takes to make it to the NBA
and then to be great to be part of the
realm Mount Rushmore like Kobe I mean
Kobe is great it's a it's a small
Brotherhood and we lost we lost a
humungous figure in our family that's
why it's tough for us to to comprehend
Theodore it really is but we are going
to celebrate Kobe bean great to hear
from you reg we'll be watching tomorrow
night Clippers and the Lakers on TNT
thank you brother love you thank you
guys
that's Reggie Miller and I knew we had a
tough day yesterday I had heard that he
had a tough day and I just thought you
know what it's good that he'll be on
Tuesday and that'll get him a little bit
of time to grieve and then you know cuz
he'd saw him as a kid and then all of a
sudden you know at age 41 and you're
like how do you process all this of
course everybody else who passed away as
well for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
a stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]